nous montre un geste qui remonte à la
nuit des temps à pratiquer ce geste avec
toutes sortes de plantes pour en
extraire le suc évidemment est-ce qu'il
faut extraire et appliqué sur les
piqûres blessure c'est ça c'est celui là
qui au soleil et vert fluo magnifique
alors les oeufs bacon pour le collyre
tout ce que l'on peut dire vous offre
pour récupérer les sucs et vous le
mettez dans l'oeil sans problème orties
pissenlit bears trois plantes sauvages
mais comestibles souvent considérés
comme de mauvaises herbes dans notre
jardin
stéphane loriot animateur au parc
naturel de chevreuse organise des
sorties découvertes pour les faire
connaître au grand public
cette plante s'appelle la lierre et là
le goût et les vertus médicinales de
l'aïe
alors que ce n'est pas de live donc je
proposais ces personnes qui disposent
souvent d'un jardin je leur ai expliqué
qui disposait dans leur périmètre proche
d'un véritable patrimoine en termes de
cartes des menus quoi manger au plus
proche donc là nous sommes vraiment dans
la les champions de ce qu'on appellerait
la filière courte qu'il comprenne que le
patrimoine naturel nous offre également
chez les peuples sauvages
un panel de plantes sauvages savoureuse
et tellement nourrissante bref tout nu
les carences sont là profitons-en
évidemment
entre 30 et 50 plants expliquer à chaque
sortie ce sont de véritables surprises
nutritionnel que l'on peut goûter et
apprécier convivialité partage de
savoirs un véritable moment de détente
je propose parfois des ateliers avec les
scolaires ont fait une sortie découverte
et l'après midi une dégustation avec
avec plusieurs recettes
je le fais que des adultes également
avec avec des enfants quand les gens me
disent je regarderai désormais mon
jardin différemment le but est atteint
évidemment qu'ils comprennent que leur
pelouse n'est pas qu'une pelouse est qu
un massif de fleurs pas aller au delà
d'un simple massifs de fleurs
je leur interdis pas d'avoir une pelouse
et d'avoir un massif de fleurs par un
massif de fleurs cultivées mais qu'il
comprenne qu'une friche
elle s'adapte forcément d'elle-même et
que dans cette friche on a patrimoine
insoupçonné may hamm un patrimoine
remarquable qu'on peut utiliser à sa
guise sans pour autant me mets la
ressource au contraire au gnr on
fabrique une ressource supplémentaire
bien son périmètre que l'on choix
différemment il faut déchirer la pole
n'hésitez pas à déchirer la feuille
là on viserait alors observer les
plantes de votre jardin vous pourrez
peut-être y découvrir quelques-unes de
ces plantes insoupçonnées mais qui
regorge de saveur